what's up believe nation happy weekend
I'm excited because I'm launching a new
series to talk to you about how to get 1
million YouTube subscribers at least I
think I'm gonna launch a new series
today's the first day and I want your
feedback to see if I should continue
this series or not so earlier this year
I hit half a million subscribers it was
an awesome day we had a live hangout as
I crossed the mark it was a ton of fun
and energy 9 8 9 8 9 5 all you chores 9
9 8 come on let's go guys 500k
that was intense I lost my voice I have
more interviews tonight this is crazy
and I'm hoping that this year I will hit
1 million at least that is my goal I am
on the path to do it and I thought I
would share once a month my strategies
answer your questions help you build a
full time income off of YouTube get your
channel to even bigger heights reaching
more people having a bigger impact and
as well as sharing my tips and
strategies I would dissect my growth
versus another YouTube creator and try
to understand where the differences lie
and give you the strategies and how to
grow quickly so today I'm gonna look at
myself versus Eric Thomas et the hip hop
preacher and let's see how we're doing
so I love using a tool called social
blade you can check it out social blade
calm to compare how I'm doing versus
other creators and look at my growth
daily it can be addicted to see how well
you're doing and here is my graph versus
Eric for the past year and let me be
clear here this is what was interesting
for me I love Eric you know would be an
honor to have him on my channel it would
be an honor to share the stage with him
at an event I consider Eric to be one of
the greatest speakers of our generation
you know he's the new Les Brown for me
and I love Les Brown young Les Brown was
is the guy that I look up to most in the
speaking industry and so I think Eric is
a way better speaker than I am at this
moment and I have a huge amount of
respect for what he's doing in the lives
that he has changed but if you look at
our YouTube channels you'll see that my
videos are crossing his in terms of
subscribers and we recently just passed
him and so what's the difference right
so looking at our social blade results
you see my line going up and you see his
line still going up but not as fast
let's look at each number if we look at
the bottom part there I'm at $569,000
he's at 58 and a bit so not that big a
difference between where we were ranking
and our users recruited about the same
time I was 2008 in November Hugh's 2008
in December but the big number that
separates me from Eric is the number of
videos uploaded I'm at 3.7 thousand
videos uploaded on my channel and he's
at 553 and if we back up if we back up
and think about what I just said about
Eric being a great speaker and one of
the one of the best speakers of our
generation how much respect that I have
for him why am I able the pass is
because I'm uploading more content and
that's part of the YouTube algorithm
they want to see regular consistent
content now you don't want to just throw
up crap right you don't want to just
throw anything up there just to get it
because people have to watch it right
you have to put something out there that
is good enough people want to watch but
I'm also believing that the quantity
leads to the quality that by practicing
by making more videos by honing your
skills you'll get better and better and
better and better better each time
and so while I only have three point
only have three point seven thousand
videos uploaded I've done another five
hundred to a thousand that have never
made it public just for me practicing
and practicing and practicing and
practicing and so it helps me get better
but for the YouTube algorithm you want
to see lots of content so I would be
looking at at least once a week I think
once a week now is is not even the bare
minimum anymore I mean they want to
really see you get to multiple times per
week if not daily content now I'm a bit
of a strange animal we're at three
videos at least per day and that's
what's helping drive a lot of the growth
and so I think a lot of people pay
attention to the wrong metric where
they're looking at how many views per
video and it's the wrong metric to look
at because what I care about
his overall views and overall subscriber
growth I care about how many people is a
message reaching net not on a per video
basis and you should too and so if
you're comparing how many views I get on
an average video compared to someone
who's uploading once a month I might
lose that game and I'm okay with it
that's a small game that's the nothing
game go to socialblade and compare my
channel to them and you'll see massive
growth for against almost anybody on
views and on subscribers because of the
upload frequency and so I would
challenge you if you're posting once a
month on your YouTube channel to get it
to at least once a week and if you're
once a week to get it to at least a
couple times a week and if you're a
couple of times a week daily like if
this is important to you this is
something that you really want to do you
have to find the time for it and you
have to post daily good content good
something you're proud of
not just mailing it in it's gotta be
good solid stuff and then you'll be able
to beat people beat people cross over
them have more impact growth subscribers
views than people who may be better than
you because you understand the algorithm
more than they do so that's my tip of
the day of the week of the month I guess
and that's how we've been able to pass
Eric on this channel and if he were to
post daily content as well he would
start crushing me
so I hope that doesn't happen but I do
think of as a gift of all the content
that he doesn't create so here's my
question I'm thinking about creating
this series I want to continue it and I
want it to be interactive and I want to
answer your questions as well and so if
I'm doing a part 2 next month what I
want to know is what are some of your
key YouTube questions concerns about
growing a channel about turning into a
business anything you have I want you to
leave that question in the comment below
and maybe next month if I do this again
I'll answer your question to help give
you some more guidance advice and help
you have a bigger impact on YouTube so
let me know what you guys think of the
series should we keep it should we kill
it and do something else leaving the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you
to believe in yourself hey whatever
you're one where it is much love
I'll see you soon